where did you go to school who gives a
[__] you pen you went to UPenn yes I did
yup yup I like how Andrew is not long
enough
yes it's very much an ivy really yeah
not really though yeah no it is like
actually it's like one it's like
Stanford
[Music]
and it's not even like Cornell you know
where that's like kind of an ice cream
is legit [__] didn't take Epstein
money whoa only Ivy I think that didn't
they like put out a letter being like we
[__] knew it I was like all right I
bet they've definitely done nothing
wrong which by the way I uh I bet their
endowment is completely clean I got so
upset yeah um I got in so much trouble
for this I did this corporate event and
uh I always do rose jokes there and
Princess Beatrice was there and you know
her dad from what Monaco or something no
her dad is prince Andrew the guy that
was like in the photo
and everybody was like so worried that I
was gonna like say something which I was
like I have to [__] address this you
know what I mean it bombed really bad
but well I was like I was like you know
um Princess Beatrice I just want you to
know like I have no judgments like about
your dad like Epstein island is actually
just a really sensitive subject for me
because a lot of my friends died trying
to swim there
and then I said um I know that your dad
did not go to Epstein Island because my
friends Chrissy Teigen and Chelsea
Handler told me they never saw him there
didn't go well it just silence just dead
silence and then I like like roasted
this like Saudis for like 10 minutes
just bombed and bombed because it was
like you know Saudi I mean we're now in
a full alliance with Saudi like you know
Hollywood is being bought by Saudi and I
was like just trying to make the point
like this is like you know what did I
say it was like oh because it was for
billionaires it was like Tech
billionaires I was like how can Saudi be
any worse than what we're doing like you
know half the people in this room uh
just moved to a desert where women don't
have rights it's called Texas and if I'm
gonna pick which one I'd rather go to
the one where I don't have to work Texas
is better than Saudi what's that Texas
is better than Saudi yeah but Saudis
like I think they're like trying to be
cool now like it's it's like so it's
Texas
yeah do you not like Texas no I love
Texas I mean I was trying to move there
a while ago but what happened to your
finger I slice it on something
WD-40 girl that come here oh did you
close your lips
they let you get first dibs on the only
fans like right when they turn 18 do you
get to look at the pictures
isn't it weird like the second you turn
18 there's a site like let's see the
[__] for five dollars dude what there's
really the [__] up [__] do you
remember People magazine uh [__] two
months ago JonBenet Ramsey was on the
cover do you remember this no two months
ago two like two or three months ago and
I'm like what the [__] going on they
couldn't like it didn't sit right that
shit's never sat right with me this like
obsession with JonBenet Ramsey this like
baby and lipstick who's JonBenet she was
the girl that got she got killed she was
like a beauty queen like it's like five
years old it was on the cover of all the
tabloids just on the cover of it again
because she had just turned 18 and on
like eight championships she would have
done she would have turned 18. she would
be 18. birthday like how would this be
people no no no no no no I get it and
that's gross it's gross it's like
pedophiles that they did a countdown to
when she would be legal you know they
did that with Hermione too yeah but why
the [__] could they put her on the cover
of people
I didn't buy it but also there was a
documentary about it where like like
people like I don't even understand how
people think this is okay like there was
a JonBenet Ramsay documentary where they
said you know because she got like raped
by someone and said oh maybe Jesus
Christ and then they said they were like
her vagina was three times the size
dude no no it's also crazy
this is why they need to go to college I
mean but it's like but why would the
mainstream media think it's okay this is
why women need to go to college women to
go to college don't put their kids in
beauty pageants that's a fact right
right right so this is why you should
promote more women going to college I
feel like you don't promote that at all
yeah well I'm not using my platform
responsibly is that what you're saying I
don't know what the [__] you're doing to
be honest with you but it's not that
either it's not that yeah what's like
the what do you want me to be doing I
want you to focus more on women's
empowerment yeah yeah
it's all over Venice and actually care
about what's going on in women's lives
and how we can push them to do things
that they could never dream of how can
you help them do that what happened in
Calgary
I was cold yeah it was really cold and I
think the progesterone that I've been on
has been affecting me there's definitely
something up what is it about it I don't
I mean you're just you're definitely
very pugnacious I think it's you I think
you bring it out of me
why is that the worst no it's sweet that
was I'm more sensitive now no I think
that like I think that we are we have
like a very brother-sister Dynamic I
think yeah you're so my brother
so do you notice that you're different
is Emma is your wife said you're
different after going on these is your
sex drive higher after going to Calgary
no
after being on these peptides no I'm not
really on peptides I was just joking oh
okay yeah got it yeah why do you feel
like your sex size was high [__] you
went on peptides and became a lesbian
peppers a lot of everyone in La is
transitioning the gate all the babies
are gay I mean
here's my thing my thing is like whoa
you did the Trump
what whoa but whoa
I did the trumpet
[Laughter]
I just feel like I don't need to know
like oh like when kids it's like this
this is this is you know Megan now
Madison now five different names for the
kids like whatever I think for me like I
grew up poor so we grow poor you're
whatever gender like your older sibling
is yeah like there's no you don't get to
pick your gender like it's just like my
an older brother I wear a hockey jersey
to school for like you know two years so
it's like when I see my friends buying
like nine different skirts and shorts
and [__] I'm just like all right this
just feels like yeah you know it's like
a very elitist thing I think in La yeah
and I think people are really gunning
for their kid to be trans why do you
think they want that it's because I
think it makes them seem more interested
is trans Kid the new like adopted black
kid oh that's interesting did you ever
see the list of when you adopt kids the
different prices what is it uh if you
want to pull it up online I don't know
my kids were three-fifths of a oh God
all right oh my gosh
well actually let's look at the prices
that was the Compromise it was the
Compromise I believe it was it was but
this is three-fifths like that is such a
weird like race so yeah no this is it
this is it that's it okay here I'll pull
it up this is from we cost the most uh I
mean Epstein exchange rate we cost the
most yeah
oh no because then unless you all get
adopted which by the way Epstein that's
how they get you bro that's how they get
you no but a white kid is expensive
status
what was the thing are we still doing
the Epstein thing do people still care
about that it's not that it's just that
I feel like I called this so long ago
but no one called what that something
was up with that scene
with you know what with me
what was fishy about Epstein that
everybody missed what was fishy
I don't what was fishy Whitney why are
you saying my name like I don't know it
Rascal you're being a skeleton
tell me tell me tell me the FCS no
billionaire dates of brunette
Jeff Bezos
married to her well there's that's not
just a brunette wait for it uh what's
the guy who owns uh or no how about this
a one billionaire dates a blonde no what
what's actually
what billionaire dates of brunette that
looks like Janet Melania brunette that
looks like Janet from Three's Company
Beyonce I don't know really get there
with the billionaire speeds they don't
age that well I think you need to go
brunette brunette because brunette
brunette there's more longevity 100 or
or what's that beautiful
French earlier I think they work harder
to preserve themselves do you think no
one takes them to the beach so they felt
like you just complimented yourself yeah
it's not like you just really
extra hard without eye cream because I'm
like I know I have to work harder in
other areas like blondes I know that
don't go to the gym
you can be like a seven face in a blonde
and be like a 10. do you really think
I'd like to be a hot brunette you have
to be like Angelina Jolie to be like a
hot blonde you can be like Julia Stiles
I prefer brunettes yeah like way prefer
okay not even close bachelor party Kate
comes out yeah
stripper comes out of the cake brunette
yeah there's a little bit of a like a no
and we're talking wiper nuts here we're
not talking Salma Hayek with pinot and
oh I guess I count them as well but like
but yeah
privilege that like the blonde thing
lasts for like a four year period yeah I
think when you first become like an
adult where you have some Freedom you're
like what's going on with these blonde
things like they look like elves it's a
little bit it's a little cool and cute I
went through that phase when I was
living in Spain I was like Swedish girls
this is kind of fun yeah yeah but
eventually you just kind of grow at it
and you see that like there's way more
longevity like like
all right look how well you've aged
thank you you're welcome I feel like
you're joking the fact that you would
even say that you feel like I didn't
watch your [__] special I watched the
special you feel like when I compliment
you I'm not telling the truth you're
about to criticize me trying to convince
you that I like you and I care about you
betterhelp.com something else is going
on Whitney no something's going on dude
you as a lesbian way more sensitive wait
I don't like it no this is I like you
getting stuck with dicks yeah when you
were getting stuck with dicks you were
way more fun now you're gaslighting me
left and right grabbing my feet
massaging it I was it that's actually
all right that's a great thing about
that massage right there you have a
strong hand oh because you played
basketball yeah yeah and you finger
women now
baby you're WNBA material
no one wants to see us either what are
you talking about if I got stuck in a
Russian prison none of you would you be
like that's good for her yeah
but stories about Andrew ever is I had
corn side seats to a Knicks game and I
was like God I'm like last minute like
one I was like I want to come to the
next game he's like no I I'm playing
tonight in my league
he was super serious about this league
for like nine months seven years ago
yeah
a memory came up on my phone of like a
clip from when we were playing league
and I spent like maybe a good 45 minutes
while taking a [__] just looking at my
old highlights
I mean I mean boy it was balling back
then I couldn't make my boys down I
might happen we got to make you a hoop
mixtape I was gonna sit next to you
during the whole game you're trying to
pretend like you know what's going on
why didn't you just get floor seats
basketball
I literally was like who would enjoy
this demo I got it you know what Andrew
but I don't want to hear you like
getting fake three seconds or like
trying to impress everybody with your
basketball knowledge when you don't know
anything about basketball I would have
been like oh have you seen the [__]
photo of me in uh front row I'll stop
you right there
[Laughter]
is it like this you just want to do this
I mean why are you so defensive yo you
really have become a woman now that
you're a lesbian
I'm not alone you told me you came on
here you're so gaslighting I feel
Gaslight listen I can't do this can we I
can't do this
foreign
[Laughter]